sure yeah like we have 41 forms of birth  control why are you getting pregnant why  are you like this is the dumbest I I  don't yeah  I'm counseling with a woman right now  she had eight abortions  and she's 20. she just turned 20. 20  yeah  I'm like that future she belongs to the  streets yeah you can't  and that was she did it because all her  life she's heard that her bushes is fine  it's not a it's not a baby  uh and it was okay to do it and then  they offered these birth control these  are morning after pills so she literally  thought it was okay she just believed  into a lie and now that she's 20 she's  thinking about what she's done and she's  depressed suicidal hating herself for it